hallo mein name ist luca um meine lieben
freunde da ich schon lange nicht mehr
auf lustige schüler antworten test
reagiert habe habe ich einfach mal ein
paar neue rausgesucht auf die wir heute
gemeinsam reagieren wer und fangen
direkt an mit dieser lustigen schüler
antwort dass eine mathematik test denn
er zeichnet dort ja irgendwelche winkel
auf und fragt dann nach einem telefon
joker
bin ich günther jauch so
immer hier die hosen an behalten als er
aber trotzdem auch lustig sein lehrer
war nie lustig
was oder nicht nachsitzen musste was
rauskommt hier wird gefragt was möchtest
du tun wenn du mal alt bist und der
schüler antwortet schlafen
schlafen ist toll das stimmt
wart ihr eigentlich auch so dass ihr
euch früher während der schulzeit immer
voll darauf gefreut hab' doch irgendwann
arbeiten zu dürfen
so dass ihr nicht mehr für irgendwelche
arbeiten lernen müsst das sind meine
fragen zu dem thema milch warum thema
milch wieso nicht wurst
berechtigte frage mein herr die beiden
beispiel für eine tierart die sich nicht
aus eigener kraft fortbewegen kann tote
tiere
so dumpf klingen
aber diese antworten sind halt alle
richtig als nächstes haben wir hier eine
sachunterrichts aufgabe einer dritten
grundschulklasse die aufgabe lautet
nenne mir eine große stadt in nrw mit k
und die antwort ist klar stadt
köln gibt's ein
dieser lustigen schüler antworten muss
ich euch gar nicht die komplette
aufgabenstellung einblenden es geht
einfach darum dass er so häufig weil als
wl geschrieben hat und er hat sogar
einmal da in der dritten zeile richtig
geschrieben dann aber durch gestrichen
und dann wieder falsch geschrieben ich
habe immer stinken falsch geschrieben
ich solle mitgeschrieben stinken bei
dieser aufgabe muss man irgendeine
trigonometrische scheiße irgendwie
irgendwas mit dem intervall extra ziel
gegen so eine mathematik über themen
hatte keine ahnung
von mathe scheiße muss man machen oder
schreibt einfach hin dieser moment wenn
man sieht das genau so eine aufgabe die
man überhaupt nicht kann sieben punkte
bringen zu aller ja schon mal geil dass
jeder in da schon rechtschreibfehler
angekreuzt hat mit roten stift
allerdings hat die lehrerin dann auch
noch darunter geschrieben dieser moment
wenn man eine identische aufgabe einen
tag vor der klassenarbeit gemeinsam
gerechnet hat und dabei mindestens drei
mal erwähnt hat dass eine solche aufgabe
drankommt
sorry aber
dann hat wirklich rein geschützen hier
sollte ein kind zehn wörter aufschreiben
dass er schon richtig buchstabieren kann
also auf englisch the words
doppelpunkt und er beschreibt einfach
diese ganzen wörter hin the world and
spa und dann oktopus 72
und amran versteht ziemlich haffter glas
diese erste aufgabe hat der
amerikanische schüler noch richtig
beantwortet hat er nämlich bobby
hingeschrieben weil die halt reicher ist
und mehr geld hat und hat dafür auch
einen haken bekommen in der zweiten
aufgabe sollte er dann allerdings sagen
how do you know you're thinking also wie
ist er darauf gekommen also die
mathematische herleitung zeichnen er hat
allerdings gezeigt was halt sein denken
war also wie er darauf gekommen ist
nämlich an bobby gedacht kinder sind so
wiedner was ihm manchmal denken hier
sollte jemand die differenz von 180 158
aufschreiben und wir ja bereits hat er
das richtig gemacht hat nämlich eine 22
in geschrieben der nächsten aufgabe
sollte allerdings dann auch erklären wie
er die antwort gefunden hat also
beispielsweise dann irgendwie 180 958
hinschreiben oder so aber nein er
schreibt einfach dass er die antwort
durch mate gefunden hat
es ist halt auch wieder einfach nicht
falsch hier sollte eine schülerin eine
kinderkrankheit hin schreiben die sie
kennt und sie hat die pubertät
hingeschrieben
den eltern würden dir da voll zustimmen
das stimmt auch
die pubertät ist einfach so eine ganz
große krankheit so kleine sachen um
symptome mit sich bringt pickel
stimmungsschwankungen
eltern sind doof ganz viele sachen alter
pubertät schlimmste hier sollte ein
schüler die kleinste nummer der reihe
einkreisen und das hat er auch richtig
gemacht
klar steht erstens zweitens drittens
wahrscheinlich für die reihen und der
lehrer hätte sich was anderes erwartet
aber es ist auch richtig
ich hätte das safe volle punktzahl für
gegeben bei diesem test geht es um das
mittelalter und man sollte hin schreiben
was man bereits über das mittelalter
weiß und ein schüler hat geschrieben
dass man jugendlich dass man schon eine
freundin hat und
das stimmt auch irgendwie
gefühlt hat in diesem märchen oder auch
mittelalter oder so mit 20 schon
geheiratet
wenn man mich früher mit zwölf jahren
gefragte der luca wo siehst du dich mit
ich bin jetzt 25
ich hätte gesagt frau kind haus alles
nichts davon erreicht
nix mehr geheiratet noch kind noch ein
haus
kann nicht mal richtig popeln als
nächstes haben wir wieder eine
grundschule aufgabe der dritten klasse
und zwar eine probe der katholischen
religion die frage lautet darauf hin
welche geschenke brachten die drei
weisen dem jesuskind mit und die schüler
antwort war gold weihrauch und eine
möhre
ich schwöre ich ich über möhren mehr
gefreut und zwar weil auch alter mir
wird immer schlecht von der scheiß ich
bin auch damals aber zusammengebrochen
in einer kirche
schlimmster geruch der welt nach sandras
füßen hier sollte ein schüler die
folgenden gleichungen lösen und den
lehrer wortwörtlich beeindrucken der
schüler hat allerdings einfach nur
darunter geschrieben es ist nicht meine
motivation anderen menschen zu
imponieren und die lehrerin hat
daraufhin geschrieben sehr gut man
sollte die fragen immer kritisch
betrachten volle punktzahl von doktor
professor mediziner luca bekommen
bildet arbeitsgruppen und erstellt eine
statistik über die zeit die die
jeweilige gruppe pro woche mit sport
verbringt gebt die jeweiligen
abweichungen an wir stellen
grundsätzlich keine statistiken über
sport wie betreiben ihn so
ich auch
dir wahrscheinlich schon auf instagram
eine fortschritte mit fitness und boxen
wie ich da gerade durch ziehe aber
generell mal ganz kurz
ich weiß ich weiß nicht was eine aufgabe
aus dem sportunterricht war aber hattet
ihr damals sportunterricht immer in der
halle sowie ich beispielsweise wartet ja
auch teilweise so theoriestunden
das hatte ich nämlich noch nie das so
häufig mitbekommen dass irgendwelche
schulkollegen von mir aus einer anderen
klasse oder so damals das dann irgendwie
sport theorie hatten damit sich in die
sporthalle gegen sachen ausfüllen ediger
meine lehrerin waren immer so toll dass
wir uns einmal ein ball gegeben meinten
komm rennt machen allerdings direkt
weiter mit der nächsten lustigen schüler
antwort aus einem test und zwar wusste
der schüler überhaupt nicht mehr weiter
und hat dann einfach eine kranke person
auf einem brett gemalt und dazu
geschrieben kriegt diese arme patient
der bald sterben wird einen zusatzpunkt
und die lehrerin hat geantwortet wenn du
das bild auf einer arbeit im fach kunst
gemacht hätte es dann vielleicht
hat zwölf mal halb von 28 punkten
bekommen und eine vier minus kassiert
der gar
nicht weniger mal und mehr lernen was
bedeutet dns ausgeschrieben dünner nix
schmecken
was sind gene chromosomen und eingehen
noten g9 genug wir erkennen
sind auf jeden fall wörter
und wie heißen die vier basen moleküle
aus denen die dna besteht peter
bernd-uwe und jochen
ich bin ganz ehrlich
solche leute würde ich direkt einstellen
weil sie einfach nur humor haben an der
stelle wird das heute wieder ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch luca reagiert endlich
mal wieder auf lustige schüler antworten
test gefallen hat das gern einen daumen
hoch unter dem video der abonniert main
kanal und klickt auf die glocke wenn ihr
weitere videos nicht verpassen wollt
jetzt
befinden wir uns im auto ihr könnt jetzt
meinen kanal abonnieren oder euch die
letzte folge von luca lustige schüler
antworten scheiße hier angucken
[Musik]